continúa la información en 324 y
hablamos ahora economía estamos para eso
con danger hablando que nos va a contar
lo más importante de hoy daniela y
empezamos hablando de cuba porque basura
de reformas económicas más importantes
desde 1960 hola liliana pues el gobierno
por lo menos lo que dice es que miles de
pequeñas y medianas empresas podrán
incorporarse en la isla en los próximos
meses por primera vez desde
1968 eso en el marco de una reforma de
la que el gobierno dio detalles esta
semana así se pondría fin al limbo legal
que en que muchos han estado incurriendo
durante décadas las empresas podrán ser
de propiedades estatal mixta o privada y
el tamaño depende del número de
trabajadores
la microempresa tiene hasta 10 la
pequeña de 11 hasta 35 y la mediana de
36 hasta 100 empleados estas nuevos mil
pymes podrán acceder al sistema
mayorista estatal importar y exportar
fijar precios y atraer inversión
extranjera pero sólo dentro de un
entorno empresarial dominado por el
estado donde estas actividades
permanecerán muy fuertemente reguladas
además siguen siendo ilegales en los
sectores considerados estratégicos para
el estado como por ejemplo la salud
telecomunicaciones energía defensa y
prensa entre otros veremos qué ocurre
daniela varias empresas retrasan su
regreso a la oficina por causa de la
variante beta liliana la multinacional
de estadounidense facebook informó a sus
más de 60.000 empleados a nivel mundial
que ya no podrán volver a sus oficinas
en octubre como se tenía planeado sino
en enero de 2022 en el mejor de los
casos esto debido al rápido avance de la
variante delta que ha llevado a otras
empresas a tomar decisiones similares
por ejemplo amazon pospuso del retorno
también hasta enero y apple lo hizo de
septiembre a octubre en el caso de la
red social fundada por mark zuckerberg
el regreso será sólo de algunos porque
ahora habrá más flexibilidad para el
teletrabajo danger precisión energía en
españa rompió nuevo récord
si casi todos los días de esta semana
los precios de la electricidad en el
mercado mayorista han batido récords el
precio ya sube de los 110 euros por
kilovatio hora cuando hace un año era de
apenas 40 es decir se ha triplicado y
todo apunta a que si las cosas siguen
como van agosto será el mes de la
energía más cara en la historia del país
todo porque por la ola de calor que
eleva el consumo de a la vez los precios
como en muchos países de españa funciona
con un mercado regulado liliana que en
su mayoría es de consumo residencial es
decir unos 10 millones de hogares y ese
precio del que hablamos representa casi
una tercera parte de la factura total
que llega a las casas hay otro mercado
que es el no regulado al que pertenece
en unos 17 millones de hogares y que por
ahora no se ven afectados con estos
precios del diaria pues para amortiguar
el alza del precio mayorista de la luz
el gobierno aprobó en junio rebajar del
21 al 10 por ciento del iva que grava el
recibo eléctrico y suspender
temporalmente unos impuestos que pagan
los generadores
a nivel la producción y el consumo de
carbón disminuyeron en europa bueno hay
un informe de eurostat que es la oficina
de estadísticas de la unión europea que
muestra como entre 1990 y 2020 la
producción de carbón se ha reducido
sustancialmente a medida que los países
han hecho la transición hacia fuentes de
producción de electricidad como el gas
natural y las energías renovables ahora
veamos en 1990 la región producida 227
millones de toneladas de carbón tipo uia
este se utiliza en industrias como
hierro y acero y la cifra ha venido
descendiendo hasta llegar a poco menos
de 57 millones de toneladas en el 2020
otro hito importante es que en la década
del 90 había 13 países productores de
esta clase de carbón y hoy sólo quedan 2
polonia y república checa hay otro tipo
de carbón que es el lignito cuya
producción y consumo también se han
desplomado en las tres últimas décadas y
finalizamos daniele con la ciudad el día
bueno son los 923 millones de dólares de
ganancias que registró disney en el
segundo trimestre de 2000 y no se
comparan con pérdidas de 4.700 millones
en igual periodo del año pasado debido a
la pandemia los ingresos de los parques
temáticos aumentaron por primera vez en
cinco trimestres aunque la variante
delta sigue acechando por otro lado la
plataforma de streaming disney más
alcanzó los 174 millones de suscriptores
siguiendo los pasos de las otras
compañías también desde daniela díaz
ustedes contribuyen con más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom